Hello everyone, welcome back to another episode of the Grand Prixquel Podcast where we discuss
all things feeder series.
On today's episode, we're going to be recapping the F2 and F3 weekends at Barcelona.
Your hosts for today are myself, Robin, Peter and Evan.
So of course before the F2 and F3 weekends actually started, we had some rookie FP1s.
So we had six teams taking F2 series drivers into their teams, so there was Dino Beganovic
for Ferrari, Leonardo Fornaroli for McLaren, Luke Browning for Williams, Colton Herta
for Cadillac, Paul Aron for Audi, Ayumu Iwasa for Red Bull and Fred Vesti for Mercedes.
So I mean, some of these drivers showed quite a good pace, I mean in particular I'd say
Fornaroli and Aron, Beganovic, they were quite, they finished practice in the top 10.
And especially Paul Aron as he finished ahead of Bortoleto in practice.
I think it's interesting that Ferrari put Dino in the car and not Camara.
Maybe they'll give Camara FP1 sessions later on in the year, I just think that's interesting.
You know, me too, maybe he'll do some with Haas, because if you think about last year,
Bearman did them with Haas as well, so.
Who did the Ferrari ones last year? I don't remember.
But the interesting thing is that with Bearman, it was clear that he's going to do this many
FP's, he's very clearly our driver, he's a big announcement when he first did it in 2024.
With Camara, he tested an F1 car, but I mean, maybe in Brazil, because there's no sprint
race in Brazil this year, so surely in Brazil they'd give it to him in front of his home fans,
Maybe Ferrari just thinks he's that bad.
Maybe that's just why he didn't get the session.
Yeah, maybe what happened in Monaco. It’s just right in their minds.
But it really makes the question of how good is he?
And then Fornaroli, I mean, also, 67.
67.
He drove the 67 car.
I don't know why they, McLaren changed the number, but they did.
Is there no one on the team who told them that 67 is a meme?
Or maybe they did it on purpose.
Zak Brown needs to appeal to the kids.
He has to expand the fanbase.
67.
And then of course, Luke Browning.
Well, he would have been in the car, but he wasn't in the car, because there's an electrical
issue.
I think if I remember right, there was a connector in the car that wasn't right.
The car was entirely torn apart and they tried to find it, and they never ended up finding it.
And I just think it's really unfortunate that Luke just didn't get a run after so much
press and hype through other, I guess, media organizations.
I think PlanetF1 might have done an interview with him and other media organizations as well.
I think there was a lot of hype for Luke to be doing this FP1, and then, well,
car electrical issues said no.
And that was that, I guess.
But at least that means he gets to do another session elsewhere.
But there's not really too many amazingly great locations he could do, like more sessions
at.
Because it's been confirmed he's doing it next week, no, well, the week after at Red Bull
Ring.
Yeah, that one was announced with his Barcelona announcement as well.
So we know that for sure.
But I guess the replacement to whatever Barcelona was meant to be, the obvious one,
well, if there wasn’t a sprint weekend for whatever reason, the obvious one would have
been the British Grand Prix, because he's British.
You know, home crowd, whatever.
But apparently it's a sprint weekend this year.
So I'm just trying to see where else he would fit in another one, because he needs to do
it in, I think, unless...
I think this one already counted for him.
No, I don't think it did.
There's no way, though, because he had no running at all.
He was just entered into it.
He never ran at all.
So from what I heard or am hearing, just in general, people were saying that it hasn't
counted.
But I guess we have to see.
I heard the opposite.
I heard people say that it did count.
It would be pretty idiotic, though, because the point of the rookie FP1 session is to
give the rookie driver the chance to drive, is from what I'm understanding is what it's
meant to be.
And so really, all that's happened on the Barcelona weekend for Luke and Williams is
that Alex Albon just didn't get to drive FP1.
It's not a case of, like, actually there's any actual rookie driving testing in that
at all.
Maybe Luke sabotaged the car on purpose because he couldn't run FP1.
So he just, like, unscrewed Alex's camera.
And that's why whatever happened in the F1 race happened.
My boy would never do that.
Your boy wants a Williams seat.
Don't you dare ever accuse him of that ever again.
I will curse Alex Powell personally, even more than he's already cursed.
What brought Alex Powell into this?
Too bad.
You brought Luke into this.
You just said that Luke sabotaged the car and he definitely did not.
I'm bringing Alex Powell into this.
So next up, we had Colton Herta for Cadillac.
Obviously, he's just getting the super license points because for every 100 kilometers he
runs, he gets one point.
And he's currently at 34 points, so he needs six more points.
Hopefully he can aim for top 10 finish in F2 to get a few more points,
but that is the aim for him.
I think if he does four FP1s, he needs a P8 in F2.
A P9 should be fine.
Oh yeah, P9, sorry.
So I don't know how possible a P9 is.
He's P12 at the moment.
He should have been higher than that.
Paul Aron was quite interesting for Audi.
I think they eventually will have Freddie in, but Freddie is only 17 at the moment.
He does have the super license points because he's won a lot of racing series.
Can't they apply for an exemption like Mercedes did for Kimi in 2024?
There's no point there if he's not going to be an F1 till 2028 anyways.
Yeah, but he might as well get the experience.
And he turns 18 in August.
I'm curious to know why Alpine lends Aron to Audi.
It's just interesting why would they not run Aron at Alpine because that's where he's signed to.
I mean, Aron did some stuff for when they were Sauber last year as well, didn't he?
I mean, yeah, maybe there's an agreement there already.
It's just interesting to me.
Audi had to get somebody.
They need at least one person.
They have no drivers in their academy right now that can do FP1 sessions on.
So I guess they had to borrow somebody.
It's just interesting that Alpine decided to move theirs till later, I suppose.
Because I mean, almost every team did something here.
So like, you know.
It's just Briatore being Briatore.
Audi or, well, at the time, Sauber ran Robert Shwartzman at one point.
But he was never going to be with Ferrari.
They did, right?
I forgot about that.
That's back when they had Ferrari engines, though, here, it kind of made sense.
I'm going Wikipedia to confirm that Robert Shwartzman actually did do it,
because I feel like he did.
He did.
I remember.
And he got a penalty for it.
He got a penalty during that session, a grid penalty that he would have to serve in his
next race, which is never.
I can love what you, it's so funny to me when you go on Wikipedia,
because I can tell when he fell off.
Because in 2023, he was testing Ferrari.
But in 2024, he's straight down to Sauber.
Like, he should have been dumped at Sauber to do testing for them.
I can see what the downfall was for him.
That's lovely.
So moving on.
We had Ayumu Iwasa for Red Bull, which I would have thought they'd bring in Tsolov.
But maybe Tsolov is going to be there for VCARB at some point.
I think also it might just be to do with they wanted to get data,
and Iwasa is arguably a more developed driver than Tsolov is.
So I think that could be part of it as well.
It's like how we've had Fred Vesti for Mercedes for those two.
It clearly is just data.
Yeah, I mean, when is Fred not doing the FP1s for Mercedes.
At least he’s no longer locked in the simulator.
Let him see the daylight.
The Mercedes is also locked into having to use Fred anyway to do their
rookie testing, or rookie FP1 testing, because their academy team has no drivers that could
possibly do it.
Yeah, every single one of their academy drivers is Formula Regional or below.
Imagine if they got Rashid Al Dhaheri in the car.
Abu Dhabi, you know, Emirati driver.
Does he have the super license points for that?
If he wins FREC, he will.
If he wins FREC.
I mean, he's leading the championship, isn't he?
You heard this here first.
Rashid Al Dhaheri doing free practice sessions.
Okay, so do we want to move on to the actual F2 weekend?
Yes, we'd love to do that.
So in practice, F2 up first.
We had Noel Leon going off in practice causing the red flag.
One of many Campos’ to have incidents this weekend.
And I think that the Campos loved that turn three gravel.
Quali was normal-ish, except for the fact that Villagomez was P5.
Yeah, and Camara had quite a big margin on the field, but that does need to be
caveated with that Miyata crashed at the end bringing out the red flag, of course.
Yeah, there were a bunch of drivers that were improving at the time.
One of them being Laurens Van Hoepen, improving to be like, I think based on the
sector time, sector 2 split.
He was only like a tenth or so off Camara.
Duerksen got a five-place penalty, I think it was five places, for not respecting yellow flags.
And his fans were obviously not very happy.
Duerksen keeps getting penalized and it's entertaining as someone who doesn't like Invicta.
I mean, the thing is, they need to balance out their favoritism towards Camara with,
you know, maybe not being so nice to Duerksen, that’s all it is.
You can't be nice to both Invicta cars, you need to make up for it somehow.
We had Herta qualify in the top ten, which was very nice.
Um, not very nice what happened later, but-
We had really big expectations for him.
I mean, the sprint race, I mean, Kush Maini, what the hell?
What is in that ART?
Seven-second win by Kush Maini of all people.
That ART is powered by money and money only.
Cause there is no way that, like, from one year to another year,
that they've improved that much.
It is clearly just money, I fear.
Oh, and look at their drivers as well, like,
I mean, you've gone from having Victor Martins to Kush Maini.
It's really a downgrade.
It's the Victor Martins luck.
As soon as he left, ART locked in.
And now he's going to Alpine Endurance,
and Alpine Endurance aren't going to be there next year, I mean.
It's the Victor Martins luck.
Also Maini, he got fastest lap, and his fastest lap was like
three tenths faster than the next closest fastest lap by another driver.
Oh my god.
And yeah, we’ll leave it to Colton Herta.
I mean, it was going really well for him until the final lap,
cause he held onto his tyres,
he made a really good overtake on Tsolov,
with this very kind of Indycar-style overtake.
You know, I kind of thought, is this finally the moment?
And then he bottled it!
In the most Colton Herta way ever.
Threw away a podium.
I am so mad.
Colton, go back to Indycar, the Indycars call for you.
I mean, he still bottled it there.
Yeah, but it's less painful than seeing him,
it's less painful than seeing him,
throw away a podium with Kush Maini on it.
I don't think too much else happened in the sprint,
apart from the Duerksen-Stenshorne incident,
where it was like more Duerksen going off
and Stenshorne getting penalized for it, I can't lie.
Well, Stenshorne got a penalty for it,
10 seconds, not 5 seconds like it says in the doc.
Oh, 10, my bad.
But yeah, I don't actually remember the incident,
so I couldn't tell you if it was, if the penalty was deserved or not.
I mean, they were kind of fighting for position,
but then, you know, Stenshorne’s ahead at the apex,
Duerksen tries to go in and he kind of,
they make a bit of contact I think then.
Duerksen must really hate the Rodins.
I mean, or maybe Stenshorne is just learning from his teammate Alex Dunne,
although Dunne has finally had two clean weekends in a row,
I think we need to applaud him for it.
What a concept of a racing driver being able to keep it clean,
especially Alex Dunne.
Out of every single driver, you least expect Alex Dunne keeping it clean,
that deserves, he deserves the championship just for that, quite frankly.
Exactly.
I mean, but he's proven though,
when he keeps it clean, he does get the results.
I mean, moving on to the feature race, you know, P3.
That fight between him and Tsolov was so good,
and I was so surprised that it didn't end in a collision or any contact at all,
they were just both of them racing really cleanly, and it was so good.
He's actually P2 in the feature race, not P3 because of the-
Yeah, Tsolov got penalized post race.
I think he ended up behind Mini after the penalty,
so the podium ended up being Camara Dunne Mini.
I mean, from the start, I mean, Dunne got the jump on the start,
Camara, I mean, that Invicta, can we please investigate it?
We need to launch a formal investigation on that Invicta because what the hell?
How do you go 22 laps on softs?
The commentators were saying that the maximum last year was 16 laps.
How do you do 22?
And still be fast?
It's not like he was massively, you know,
you know, like, conserving his pace, saving his tires.
FIA investigate.
Please, please.
There's something shady going on.
Dunn and Mini both got, like, hit by traffic after they pit,
which really did help Camara, but-
But he was still doing semi-decent lap times.
It is so weird.
And then we had, yeah, Tsolov, I mean, Tsolov did the alternate strategy.
Most drivers, they went soft hard, Tsolov went hard soft.
Yeah, so, I mean, he was really making up time at the end,
and he would have been P2 if he didn't overtake Mini off track.
Did you see, like, I don't remember whether it was in the Steward's Doc
or whether it was in the article on the F2 page,
but they were talking about how they needed to use high resolution cameras
to see whether Tsolov went off track or not.
Does that imply that the cameras aren't high resolution then?
Like, what is that?
Does that imply that the cameras are not high resolution?
Oh, you need to use high resolution cameras.
Surely they can solve this issue by just having an automated system which can detect.
The issue is that, like, the only, just like, the issue of that is that
it's dependent on GPS, potentially.
The only most accurate way we have to determine, like, location,
like, the locational position is GPS.
And GPS is also horrifically unreliable.
It is, like, the most reliable, the least reliable technology we have,
or, like, something like that.
And the only other alternative, to me at least,
is that you have the lines on the track,
like, a camera on the nose cone or something,
that can, like, do some, like, magic AI, whatever,
to determine if a wheel is, like, oh...
The point is that you can't really do that without, like,
there's actually no way to do it.
They have to manually actually look at the footage,
which is why I find it funny they said high resolution cameras,
because that implies that cameras aren't high resolution at all.
Apparently, Tsolov was only very marginally off the line,
so they had to use, like, high resolution cameras, apparently.
My question is, what qualifies as a high resolution camera?
Like, did they have, like, were one of the TV directing cameras,
like, one of the TV cameras pointed, like, pretty, like, right behind Tsolov?
Like, what do they mean, we use high definition cameras,
or high resolution cameras?
What do you normally use, then?
Yeah, to my knowledge, they determine, like,
a lot of the decisions are determined based off, like,
the cameras, like, on the track, like, the track cameras,
as well as maybe the T-cam.
Does this have somebody recording on, like, their iPhone 6?
I'm genuinely curious, like, what do you mean?
Like, why did they have to make a distinction between
like, the fact that it was a high resolution camera specifically?
That's also semantics that doesn't really matter,
but yeah, Formula 2, please explain.
I'd love to know.
Average F2 experience.
I think other than that, of course, Ollie Goethe.
I mean, he's had a bit of a painful race.
He didn't even do the formation lap.
As he gets pushed, and then he makes it about 100 meters outside the pit exit,
and the car dies again.
He's just had been having pretty bad luck in general, honestly, just like...
I saw a post.
On Twitter.
That was like, he somehow got McLaren's reliability,
because the car is orange.
I'm not calling it papaya, because the MP car is not papaya,
but it's almost McLaren papaya.
So somehow, the McLaren reliability has transferred over to him.
I think Herta.
I mean, the pain continued in this way.
Yeah, I...
What even happened to him?
He was running in the top 10, and then suddenly he wasn't.
The pit cycle messed him up.
He basically got undercut by, like...
He got undercut by Stenshorne and Beganovic,
and then he just couldn't make up the positions.
We need to nuke HiTech.
It was going really well, I remember.
He overtakes Tso-
He's looking that he may overtake Varrone,
but then the whole pit cycle just messed him up.
And then he had all the people on the,
who went on the alternative strategy.
He went hard-soft,
and the end was coming,
and the naturally softs are a lot faster than the hards.
So they were just coming through, and yeah, it was just...
I mean, at least the sprint race showed something.
I hope that if he can qualify on the top 10 again next week,
at Redbull Ring, and of course,
that is a great circuit for overtaking.
It's also a great circuit for track limits.
Colton…
Oh, and gravel.
Speaking of track limits,
we had a couple penalties over the weekend for track limits.
Shields got two penalties during the feature.
Bilinski and Villagomez both got two during the sprint.
If we had bad track limits this weekend,
imagine how it's going to be at Austria.
But are they going to be using the high-resolution cameras in Austria?
They're going to be using an iPhone 5 from 2012
to do all the TV direction,
so that's why they need the high-resolution cameras.
They have a camera positioned at each exit, just to see.
There's probably some guy out in the stands recording it,
and that's what they're using.
I'm still stuck on the high-resolution camera thing, by the way,
because there are like four different types of cameras
that are used around a circuit.
And yeah, the high-resolution camera
is a completely different camera to those.
Like, so your TV camera, you got the ground cameras,
the ones in the ground, you got the T-cam,
and then you have maybe the drone or whatever,
or the flying, whatever, the suspended camera.
Where does the high-resolution camera fit in, then?
But whatever, I think I've gone on too much
about the high-resolution camera thing.
I guess we'll find out next weekend.
So in terms of the championship,
before Tsolov’s penalty, he was leading the championship,
but then he got penalized, so now he's not.
So Mini still leads the championship on 86 points,
Tsolov in P2 on 80, Camara on 69, and Dunne on 67.
I think it's really funny that Camara’s on 69,
and Dunne is on 67.
Then Noel Leon is in P5 on 54 points, and Beganovic P6 on 53.
All I’m going to say is our curse continues.
We said last week that Tsolov would surely overtake Mini
for the championship lead in Barcelona.
Look, technically he did.
He did at one point.
He did for a couple hours, for like an hour.
So was the curse really working there?
I don't know.
I'm only saying this because I'm the one who said that Tsolov
should be ahead of Mini.
The curse really did work,
because he had the happiness of leading the championship for an hour,
and then it got taken away from him.
But I think the championship
fight is going to be between the top four.
I think Beganovic could work his way in, because I remember the start of the season,
he was quite fast, he was just unlucky, and maybe he can work himself in somehow.
I think.
For once, the top four drivers in the standings are the top four best drivers in the championship.
I think it's evened out with any bad luck and stuff.
Even though it could seem like a big gap of 20 points, one DNF turns it around completely.
Given F2 and Mecachrome, you never know who's going to explode next.
That sounds so ominous.
You never know who's going to explode next.
Am I going to get blamed for whoever gets
Mecachromed next week?
Team standings, Campos leads on 134 points,
Rodin is in P2 on 115, MP is in P3 on 98, then Invicta on 90, and Dams on 65.
Again no surprises there,
cause I mean, like Rodin, they probably have the strongest driver lineup with Dunne and Stenshorne
overall I'd say, and even Campos, I mean, Tsolov is good, Leon is solid enough.
So I'd say things have now quite evened out in F2, cause this is what, our fifth weekend I think?
I think so.
Yeah, you’ve now had enough representative
weekends for it to eventually even out, cause it's not like after Miami when you only had two
weekends there's not enough has happened to fairly judge, but now there are clear trends,
and I do still feel like Tsolov is the fastest, and probably the best driver in the championship.
Dunne is the fastest, he's just not consistent,
and by consistent I mean he keeps crashing, but he's stopped that.
But if he keeps it tidy, if he keeps it up,
he could have a solid championship result, and if he does really well,
I mean, and if he does really well, he could put pressure on Alpine and Franco Colapinto cause
he has motivation to do it as well, but then again that could make him lose his head,
the thought of an F1 seat.
We’ll have to see, who knows, maybe when F1 Silly Season
properly gets started, we'll see whether that gets to his head or not.
And then next up, we had of course the
Formula 3 weekend. We knew after Monaco, in classic Grand Prixquel luck, the day after we
record, hours after we record, the Benavide replacement gets announced.
We were literally talking on the episode about how
it would be really annoying if they announced it straight after we recorded, and then not even
hours after we record. It wasn't really announced, we just saw the entry list,
which was really annoying, and I said on the episode that I was going to cry if it happened,
so I will cry.
Yeah, so he was replaced by Riccardo Escotto.
I mean, I think it’s for Barcelona cause they're both managed by the same person,
so given how last minute this was, they had to really find somebody within literally a few days notice.
So there is going to be somebody different for the Red Bull Ring.
We believe there's going to be someone
different.
We believe. I mean, I'd love it for it to
be KNB cause that would be hilarious.
It would be so funny.
Yeah, Riccardo Escotto, there's nothing
very notable about him. I mean, he's currently losing to Niels Koolen in IndyNXT.
How do you- How do you manage that?
I mean, for reference, Koolen is in the better team, but still.
His best finish in IndyNXT is P7,
but yeah, not a very notable IndyNXT driver. I can't lie, when it was announced that he would
be doing Barcelona, I was like, who the hell is that? I did not realize he was in IndyNXT.
He's kind of a bit irrelevant.
Yeah, but I think with AIX, for the next round,
it’ll be the case of whoever can pay would get it.
Who's the biggest pay driver in
Formula Regional level at the moment?
I'm going to say, look at F4, we have
Maccagnani.
Maccagnani is not going up to F3 for a round-
I mean, Al Dhaheri? Al Dhaheri maybe?
Potentially.
We'll have to see. I swear to God if they announce it after the episode again, I'm going to-
I don't know what I'm going to do.
I mean, at least the entry list comes out
next week rather than today.
Yeah, exactly.
Yeah, so looking at practice,
nothing too notable, but oh my God, the Campos’. 1-2-3 What is this Campos rocket trip?
I would much rather Campos domination
than Trident domination, just because it means that if Alex Powell joins them next year,
he's going to be good. Just trust me. I really want Alex Powell to join them next year.
Um, quali I remember the ARTs and the VARs were
really good.
Yeah, and the Campos’. I mean,
Campos were 1- they were 1-2-7. And the VARs, all of the VARs were 3-6-8. I think it's quite
clear to me who the top two teams are. It's Campos and VAR, and that is-
Really?
I mean, at least this weekend.
Yeah, I think- I don't know if VAR's
performance this weekend was a fluke or not.
VAR are second in the team's championship.
Yeah, but they've gotten a lot of their
points from the sprints. I mean, Del Pino has two sprint podiums. Yamakoshi ended up on a sprint
podium. Deligny ended up on a sprint podium.
I mean, I am biased as a Freddie fan because
he was only P10 in quali, but I do think that Trident have taken a step back from where they
were last year because I look at where Stromsted is. Stromsted is in the same team and is doing
worse this year than he was last year.
Or maybe your goat is washed.
Maybe, but I'm just looking at Stromsted
as my reference point. And it's clear, yes, Campos have good drivers, but also, I mean,
the Campos’ just seem fully locked in in their cars and how it is. And yeah, Freddie was, but all
the Tridents were kind of washed this weekend. I don't want to talk about the race with Freddie.
I mean, I wanna talk about the sprint race, you know, he was P2 in the sprint race.
I think the sprint was kind of really weird
because we had James Wharton winning.
Prema is good bro calm. We had surprisingly clean starts, at least for the sprint race.
I don't know about the feature race. I was not there for the start of the feature race.
I think they’re still traumatized from the
Monaco sprint race.
But yeah, so surprisingly clean start. I laughed when Ugo spun behind Enzo. He was
really rattled by Enzo's aura.
I mean, again, it was Turn 3, Turn 3 and Campos just weren't mixing this week.
I know it wasn't because of Enzo's aura,
but in my head it was because of Enzo's aura.
Oh, yeah, no, he was just, he saw Deligny
and was like, oh my god, he's gonna 6-7 me.
Maybe Enzo did a 6-7 before the corner and then he felt it.
I mean, knowing Enzo, he probably did.
Both Rivera and Colnaghi ended up DNFing, which is really sad.
For Rivera it was actually quite interesting, ‘cause Rivera had an electrical issue
and that caused Badoer to go into him and initially Badoer was given a penalty for
that, but then Campos showed really good sportsmanship by basically telling the
stewards, they triggered a right of review saying, it's not his fault, it's the other car's fault,
which you know, I like that.
Colnaghi, I don't know what happened to him, but he like went into the pit lane
in the beginning of the race and then I don't think he stopped in the pit lane, I think he
went on to the end of the pit lane so he started in the pit lane for whatever reason
and then he went back into the pits.
He stalled on the formation.
Did he?
Yeah. Someone stalled.
I don't remember.
And then the feature race, which I don't really want to talk about because-
Because your goat is washed.
The feature race podium was Nael, Yamakoshi and Ugochukwu. Badoer was up there, I think he's
been pretty consistently good so far this season.
Yeah, he has. He's kind of been silently in the back. He's just kind of lurking there.
Yeah, I was not expecting that going into the season, but I've been pleasantly surprised.
I mean, maybe with some drivers, you know, they just take one season to get
settled and then the second season, you know, they fully know and I think also maybe changing
teams has helped him.
Yeah, I mean, he was with Prema last year, wasn't he?
But also, like you know, Ugochukwu and Leon are both. I mean, Ugo is a very good driver,
Leon is solid, but in Rodin and maybe it's more of a relaxed environment as well,
there's not as much pressure. He's no longer with McLaren as well, that pressure from an F1 team
is gone.
But yeah, so the VARs again were really good. I mean, we had Yamakoshi P2,
Deligny P5 and Del Pino P6. It would have been really funny if they were 6th and 7th,
but they're not. So whatever.
They are 6th and 7th in the standings though.
Yeah, Deligny and Yamakoshi are 6th and 7th.
But like you see the top seven, I mean, all three Campos’, all three VARs.
And then Badoer.
Yeah. And Freddie, would’ve been up there if he just wasn’t washed.
He'd already been overtaken by Deligny before his penalty.
He would have been 7th without the penalty.
It's not that bad of a drop. I mean, he's, where is he? 9th?
He was 8th. He gained one spot. But if he gained one spot,
that would mean he was P3 and points, not P4.
He'll make it up. It's fine, whatever.
I mean, I can't lie, I don't remember much from the feature race. But the championship is looking
quite interesting, I think, because the top four are only separated by 11 points.
I still wonder what Campos are going to do if Ugo and Theo end up in a title fight.
Yeah, I mean, even 17 points is the gap if we include Badoer, which I mean, I can't lie,
I would have thought Ugo would have had a bigger lead.
I think that spin in the sprint didn't really help him.
And also losing out to P2, to Yamakoshi,
not being on the podium in Monaco. But I mean, it's left this championship fairly wide open.
And like, Del Pino is still keeping up there. I think he's finished the sprint race and the
feature race in the same spot, so I can no longer call him a sprint merchant.
I am surprised Del Pino is up there.
I think also, I mean, maybe once we get to more of the traditional races,
because you know, Melbourne and Monaco, both street circuits, is not entirely
representative. But
Both Deligny and Del Pino finished the sprint and the future in the same spots,
fifth and sixth for both.
It should have been one spot lower each of you.
More points for Enzo, I'm happy with that.
Yeah, Enzo is on 28, I think. Yeah, they're quite a step back from the top five,
but you never know what could happen.
I saw the championship standings after, what is this, round three, four?
Three out of nine.
I saw the championship standings after Imola last season. And you know who was in
P6 in the standings at that time? It was Nikola Tsolov. Where did Nikola Tsolov finish that
championship? P2?
Exactly. Enzo is going to end up P2 in the championship. You heard it here first, trust me.
But there is one less round this year compared to last year.
The math does not concern me. The delusion concerns me.
And then to the team championship, I mean,
Campos have like a 30 point lead in the team championship.
I mean, Fork found in kitchen, I'm not surprised.
I think it is also combined by the fact they have a good strong driver lineup as well.
And like I said, VAR is in second with 99, and there's quite a step back to third and fourth,
Rodin and Trident with 57 and 56. Okay, Freddie may have been washed this week,
but he is still carrying Trident. I mean, he scored 80% of their points.
Trident is a lot lower than I thought they would be. I really did think
they would fight with Campos for the team's title, but maybe it'll be Campos versus VAR.
I think it's more, I think it depends
more on the drivers because, okay, I would have, I would expected more from Stromsted.
He's solid. He showed like, he is solid, maybe not on the level of Freddie, but he's still
competent at a decent drive, and even, I mean, De Palo. I mean,
yes, he was runner up last year in FREC, but apart from that, he's never really showed too much.
I think he is just like your average driver,
but F3 hasn't really shown much for him. Maybe he just needs a second season. Maybe
we'll see more of him next year. Who knows? But yeah, I think that's it. I don't have anything
more to say.
No, I feel like these weekends were kind of, they were more eventful than Monaco,
but they weren't that eventful.
Yeah. There isn't much to say, especially because the only feeder series we had on
were F2 and F3. There was nothing else that we cover on the podcast. So, unfortunately,
kind of an uneventful weekend.
We did have karting, which I did tune into a bit.
Baglin had the opportunity to win the title, and he just had a massive off week,
which was disappointing for me. I do quite like him. But I mean, next time out, he should,
I mean, he's decent enough at a 30-point lead, I think he should be able to win it as long as
he keeps it clean.
I haven't kept up much with karting for a good while. I don't know why, I just haven't,
but I follow an account that does karting updates for OKJ and OK. And just every single
karting weekend, it's like, Baglin on top, or Green on top. It's always those two.
I mean, Baglin had won four finals in a
row, so I think.
Um, but yeah, other than that, there's nothing much to say, unfortunately. I think this episode
is a little shorter than usual. I don't know, I can't actually tell how long we've been filming.
I think we've been filming for about
40 minutes, which-
It's been 45 minutes, but a lot of it will be edited out. So that's it for today's episode of
the Grand Prixquel Podcast. We hope you enjoyed. Make sure to follow us on all our socials,
Twitter, Instagram, and TikTok @grandprixquel, and let us know if you have any comments or
anything you want to say about this episode. Next week, we'll be doing a recap of the upcoming
Italian F4 and FREC weekends at Monza, so make sure to tune in for those, and thank you for listening.